so you think you know better than
Christ you think there's something
better than
crucifixion there's nothing more
fulfilling than
crucifixtion
full body
surrender to new
earth expanding all of the
contractions healing
all of border
conflicts of the deepest
pains giving yourself fully to
that you think that the other programs
that you're
running are superior to
Christ that's
arrogance arrogance equal
sign programs other than Christ are
superior Christ is not the most Superior
program equal sign
arrogance and that's pretty annoying to
hear for those programs that are
running because it means means that in
order to
live in the most fulfilled way those
programs that you've identified
with will need
to collapse dissolve be
annihilated the entire body will need to
be
crucified a whole
re-calibration
to the most unimaginable
fulfillment where every single moment
the cells of the body feel like
sunlight the ultimate
limitlessness giving yourself fully to
the
whole that my
whole my body is the
whole the whole is my
body and all I care about is my body
being like the
sunlight all the cells of my body being
like the
sunlight the body's completely given
over over to
that to free
energy to basic needs abundance for
all to the deepest
wounding in the collective and healing
it expanding those
knots the hatred of people against other
people but are you Christlike
enough are you Christlike enough to
sacrifice everything to sacrifice all
the
programming to sacrifice every single
assumption to
crucify
fully and can you can you handle this
can you handle this kind of military
General balanced with the more
[Music]
calm equanimous
love can you handle that
balance do you know how to live that
balance
do you know how to surrender and
transcend all selfishness all selfish
interest to live the perfectest stream
of fulfillment
imaginable where your cells radiate
sunlight
I love you but [__]
you because you swim in
circles
pretending to be separate pretending to
lack pretending to be unworthy and need
validation pretending like there's this
massive spiritual
journey to what you already
are and so because of that addiction
that
attachment those
programs you swirl around in
discontent
forever discontent discontent
discontent always needing something
always lacking always
more crucifixion is the only
fulfillment
all selfishness has to go in order for
God to be
present all selfishness has to go for
present
so it all boils down to knowing better
than
Christ Christ is the symbol for
crucifixion of all egoic
self-interest into the totality into the
whole into the father into the universal
into
love
and then it integrates with
rebirth into the field into the
battlefield into the
stage of
Earth by
shepherding the whole into new Earth
into abundance for all into free energy
into healing and love and
prosperity peace Bliss Joy
creativity you notice the story doesn't
end with the crucifixion into something
that's Transcendent and then
nothing you notice
that notice it
because the real
test is if from there you can rebirth
into fully surrendered serving the
whole radiating like sunlight in all the
cells shepherding the collective
transformation
dying into that dying into that but you
think you know better than
Christ you think that there's something
better to do than to take on all of the
collective
sin you think there's something better
to do than to take on all of the
collective sin
but the number one lesson of God the
number one lesson of
limitlessness is to take on all of the
collectives
sin an action
when the Divine masculine is
ignited from that crucified rebirth
place the only thing that flows through
its
body
is expanding all of the
contractions of the collect
Ive nothing else
matters but taking on all of the sins of
the
collective if you can get that one line
of
code into your cess poool of
[__] and have it obliterate all of
the
conditioning and
have the
rebirth from that
place of taking on all of the collective
sin you will finally feel the Pinnacle
of fulfillment
imaginable there's nothing else to do
here that's another way to look at it
you can try endless
programs the
Antichrist is the running of endless
programs that are not
Christ the Antichrist is the running of
infinite endless programs that are not
Christ and so you'll notice that any
program that's not Christ any script
that's running that the body runs that
is not Christ is
inherently
unfulfilling it is
unfulfilling and you know it you know it
is unfulfilling you know it's
unfulfilling and yet you keep
masturbating on unfulfilling programs
pretending like Christ is not your
answer to
fulfillment you know Christ is your
answer to fulfillment you know you need
to crucify all of your [__] scripts
in order to feel the Fulfillment of
taking on the collective sins and
healing the totality to abundance and
prosperity you know that that's the only
pathway and you pretend like it's not
the only pathway and you spin around in
all kinds of cesspools of circles of
programs and scripts and nonsense and
masturbations and then you hear a
catalyst like this and then finally it's
ah
[__] that's the reflection that I
wanted [__] all these
scripts I hate these
scripts actually Christ is the answer it
is the
portal to
God
Christ is the portal to
God take the
portal take it take it you came to take
it you didn't come for another loop
masturbating in scripts that are useless
just for you to come back
again to have another Rodeo where you
miss it again and again and again and
again cuz you keep pretending like
Christ is not it you keep pretending
like you can go on without crucifying
your
self and find separation or find
fulfillment that way you can't
fulfillment can't be found with a
separate sense of self fulfillment can
only be found as the
universal end of
story end of
story and the number one way that the
universal expresses itself is
transforming Earth out of its
contractions into its healed expansions
of free energy of basic needs abundance
of prosperity for all of children being
born free do you even know what it means
for children to be born free do you even
know can you even for one minute put
your sense of self out of the
way to imagine what it would be like for
generations to come for children to be
born completely free
in a world of free energy in a world of
basic needs abundance for all in a world
where they get to wake up and play and
be creative and authentic every single
day but you spend no time imagining that
because you spend all your time in your
contracted sense of self and
separation and you master on that
endlessly including the entire spiritual
industrial complex which has endless
pollutions and perversions and
distractions away from the portal of
Christ you just think you know
better and when that ego
surrenders I don't know
better Christ is the answer crucifixion
is the answer the universal is the
answer God Is The
Answer Love Is The Answer Unity is the
answer abundance for all is the answer
that is the only sense of fulfillment
that is the only sense of fulfillment it
will not be found anywhere else absolute
period and stop pretending like it will
because it won't it will never be found
it will never be found outside of Christ
it will never be found outside of
crucifying your separate sense of self
into the totality that is God that is
love that is Unity that is abundance for
all and dying dying into that it will
never be found fulfillment will never be
found outside of a complete death of the
separate sense of
self
take this as your last
reflection take this as the last thing
that you
needed in order to give up every single
conditioned
idea that wasn't Christ is the UL portal
to
God treat this as your last reflection
my
friends because the new Earth is
here it is here and it is
now and we are the Warriors we are a
distributed team of new Earth
Warriors that are
equals in how we radiate sunlight onto
Earth God is here God has never left God
has always been here and you are playing
hide and seek and you are
pretending to be amused by your little
distractions and games of programs and
scripts that are complete [__] and
nonsense and making you suffer and feel
unfulfilled and then finally one day you
turn just like the parable of the
prodigal son you finally
turn and you finally find the Portal
that was never missing that was always
there and all you have to surrender is
everything all you have to surrender is
everything you have to surrender
everything only innocence can be let
in you have to ser surrender
Everything full crucifixion full
crucifixion and full
rebirth into
only new
Earth only healing the entire Collective
only the collective is my body the
collective is my body the collective is
my body
and I will die for this Collective to be
completely healed transformed expanded
Into Love Light Unity Bliss peace
creativity Harmony abundance Prosperity
basic needs free
energy I will die for that I will die
for that that is the constitution of a
crucified and rebirthed Christ of God in
flesh that is God in
flesh and you better believe
it there is no higher expression of
God's will than a complete
death into selfless service for the
totality
you think you know better and so you
spin around in all kinds of things like
video games and going to the bar and
watching all kinds of sports and doing
all kinds of spiritual
seeking and chasing all kinds of
substances and and traveling and trying
to get it through sex trying to get it
through money trying to get it through
luxurious objects trying to get it
through the validation of your parents
trying to get it through the validation
of others
online you try to get fulfillment
through all of the most [__] ways
imaginable and that is why you are
getting this reflection because you are
running [__] scripts and you are
asking for this reflection to liberate
yourself from those [__] conditioned
scripts so that you can die die into the
portal of Christ that is always there so
you can be God in flesh so you can
finally die on this sword for the
collective's transformation into love
light Unity Prosperity
abundance you want it so bad that's why
you asked for this video you want it so
bad you seek everywhere for it but you
have to crucify all of your sense of
self you have to Cru crucify all of the
sense of Separation you have to crucify
all of the conditioning all of it
everything has to go every single last
Speck has to go everything has to be
healed everything has to be
transformed everything has to be
repented all sins have to be repented
all of
them there's no other
way there's no other way to a fulfilling
life
Christ is the
savior crucifixion is the only
fulfillment rebirth as God in flesh is
the only
fulfillment as the totality is the only
fulfillment
selflessly serving the totality
transformation to wholeness to love to
Unity Prosperity
abundance the defense mechanisms are
strong in this Collective the defense
mechanisms are strong they grip so
tightly they grip so tightly and they
listen like foxes like arrogant foxes
they listen to these messages and these
broadcasts and they take no action
towards
crucifixion that's what you
get being a fox an arrogant Fox
listening to this and taking no action
towards
crucifixion
endlessly just sitting there consuming
all kinds of
[Music]
content without taking any
action without
repenting without taking on the
collective sins
so
arrogant you want the
sunlight to be the nature of your body
and your
cells you want
it but you don't want the cruci a
fiction to get it so what you do instead
is you pretend like you're going to get
it from all these other scripts and
programs and conditioned ideas and
propaganda that you've been
fed and you keep tripping balls on all
of that endlessly and endlessly and
endlessly and
endlessly and you might get a little bit
of a reflection from one of these videos
but completely ignore it and go
on
but one day it
strikes that strikes and when that
strikes God
wins God takes over all of your separate
self all of your ego
all of
it Eden all of
it and so continue
onward because that will
come and when it comes all of this will
be obvious you'll rewatch
this when you'll be like oh my
gosh
all that matters is New Earth how could
anything other than new Earth matter you
think you know better than Christ you
think you know better than a full bodied
surrender into new Earth you think you
know better that's what's happening you
think you know better than a full-bodied
surrender into new
Earth into basic needs abundance and
prosperity for all into free energy you
think you know better you think you're
little programs of selfing your little
scripts that are running you think that
all of those are better than
Christ and so that's what's happening
that's what's happening until they're no
longer better than
Christ and that's the deconditioning
that's the great unraveling That's The
Purge
all of those nasty ass conditioned
programs and ideas of separation and
hating others and lack in a separate
sense of self and all of that goes away
unworthiness all of it goes away all of
it's vomited purged out of the body all
of it all of it's
purged a tour of repentance so much
repentance uncontrollable repentance
just the body itself just effortlessly
repents all of its sins it takes on all
of the sins of the collective it takes
on the transformation of the
collective's wounds to the love and
light of
God of the very
son for all bodies and all cells and all
bodies to be completely transformed into
sunlight
what would it look like
if what was hearing this voice right now
what was hearing this voice right
now
said I will only build new
Earth I will
only actualize
all bodies to be
sunlight what would
change what would
change what would change when the next
day the script would no longer be
running the very thing that's hijacking
God's flow towards the new Earth and
instead directing it towards all kinds
of distorted games of separation and
validation and
unworthiness and
objectification and spiritual seeking
and all kinds of
distortions If instead there was waking
up and none of those scripts were
happening and instead the only script
that was was happening was God commands
this body for the new Earth and that's
it God commands this body for the new
Earth and that's
it just imagine that you're waking up
and all that's happening is God's
commanding the body for the new
Earth that's it that's
it learning the energetic mastery itself
to help heal and transform the
collective wounds to expand the
contractions to build the new Earth
abundant systems of energy of homes of
communities of food of water of
sovereignty of sovereignty of
sovereignty sovereignty and free freedom
freedom for children for women for men
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom what if the what was waking up
every single morning was only
constituted and guided as a Just Pure
Freedom for
all you think that you can find
fulfillment outside of that but you
can't the only way to find fulfillment
is through
that freedom freedom for all freedom for
the totality freedom of new
Earth
the only
ones that resist this message are the
ones that are
possessed if you resist this message you
are possessed
the program has you the scripts have
you Satan which is the child of God
running a muck has
you and that's just the way it
is as long as you're
pro lack
preparation pro
war
pro- individual agenda over God's
will for New
Earth there's only suffering
there and it's
the Timeless Story the Timeless story is
suffering until
crucifixion
the Timeless story is suffering until
crucifixion that story will never change
it will never change it is the most
timeless
story suffering until crucifixion or
Satan until
Christ
and you can portal into Christ
anytime Christ is already there Christ
is what is listening to this
voice Christ is already there listening
to this
voice it's
ready it's ready it's
ready God God take me
over I give myself fully to
you I give myself fully to your
will puppet the body for the new
world I am done with all of my
ideas I am done with all of my running
around trying to find fulfillment
outside of
you so I Surrender and give myself
completely to you
father take the body build a new
world do as you
please my will is your will
take me fully for your wildest
dreams for an earth prosperous and full
of
Celebration the most beautiful thing
imaginable take me fully for
that take me fully for that
because I want the Fulfillment of
that I want the Fulfillment of building
that new world for women children men to
come for
generations and enjoy the fiesta the
parte take me take me God take me I am
yours
the portal is always there my friends
the portal is always there just give up
the scripts give up the programs give up
the conditioning give up the ideas give
up the chase outside of God it will
never
happen you will never find God outside
of
yourself you will never find God outside
yourself
you will find it inside of
yourself and inside of all around you as
the
totality you'll find it as nature itself
as the universe
itself and there will be nowhere to
go but into that warm blanket of God
God's
love which is always
here and then to
fearlessly
die on The Sword of the new
world this is not being passive this is
not being
passive Christ is against
corruption get that through your skull
Christ is anti-corruption
Christ is anti-g greed it's anti-
selfishness it's anti-
hoarding it's anti-
ego Christ is not passive about that
Christ is active Christ is roaring for
Truth for God to
win
Christ actively engages in creation to
transform it into wholeness and love and
abundance for all it is not
passive
passivity in spirituality and Awakening
is unreal it's
unreal the real is only the integration
into the Flesh and into the new world
into dying for the new
world God is Not passive my friends God
rages wrath all over the injustice of
Earth this is the end of the story do
not pretend like there are there is no
corruption for God's Wrath to
Roar and expand those contractions do
not pretend like there are no innocent
children that are being sex trafficked
do not pretend like there are no Global
elitists that are sucking money out of
the poor and middle class do not pretend
like our social contracts are biom
mimicked like the nature of Mycelia and
root networks do not pretend like this
is already completely expanded because
it is absolutely not we are to Roar
God's Wrath all over the injustices of
Earth and expand all of those
contractions into the new
world
that's
Christ that's Christ a totality of
taking on all
sins transforming all of
them it is not pretending like there are
no corruption or contractions or greed
or selfishness or ego or hoarding oh
just pretend like it's not
there that's not it that's not it that's
not
it neither is saying that everything is
God that's not it either God has wrath
God has rage for
Injustice unleash the rage for
Injustice no Injustice will live none
none will live that is the Divine
masculine that is
it it Roars and
rages to transform and expand all
injustices all of them not a single
Injustice will live not a single
Injustice will
live that is what one dies into that is
what one surrenders into
to God
effortlessly takes back its Collective
from the Satanic programs so that it can
be a celebration of abundance and
prosperity for all women children men
for generations to come get that through
your thick
skull
but without this
Stillness Christ is
not the Stillness is the fundamental
backbone to Christ to
God and then from there is the Wrath
against
Injustice and the excitement for New
Earth this is not rocket science it is
so simple it's already there it's
already listening to this voice what is
listening to the voice is stillness it's
already Stillness listening to this
voice you just believe it to be a
separate self but it's not it's
Stillness it's the entire universe
listening to this
voice
and then from that Stillness that
doesn't have any attributes it doesn't
have any ideas it's open it's spacious
it's loving it's unified from that place
from that
place without a name without a location
without
identity without any of those things
from that place from that place then is
the wrath for against all
Injustice and the warrior for New World
from that place from that place it's
obvious God is playing a game with
himself which is you playing a game with
yourself which
includes the appearance of these
satanic
programs that are anti-
holism they're anti- nature they're
anti-human they're Pro greed Pro
corruption pro- selfishness Pro ego and
all of those are to be destroyed with
the fiery Breath of
God in all of these blueprints for the
New World Systems of energy abundance
housing abundance food water
abundance all those blueprints are to be
actualized again with God's excitement
for celebration and prosperity for
generations to come for a beautiful
unification and harmony with
nature
so my
friend what's listening to this
voice have it
pretend like it actually is right
now
already what it's looking
for just for I can
imagine that it's already what it's
looking
for and now let
that
be What
flows let that be
it
cease
the ideas that you know better than
Christ cease all those ideas stop all of
them all of those
scripts because you know how futile they
are you know so cease all of them and
just watch what remains when there's no
more scripts of
selfing
huh okay good cuz what remains is
Christ what remains is the father in
Flesh on
Earth selflessly serving the collectives
transformation into the new
world
okay and that
includes roaring at the
injustices
okay
it's very easy it's already
here so again give up all of those
programs all of those
scripts you know they're all an
illusion you know you keep biting into
them clicking into those ads hooking
into them running those scripts running
those programs and seeing exactly how
unfulfilling they are you keep doing it
over and over and over over and over and
over and over and over again day after
day after day after day after day oh
unfulfillment oh unfulfillment oh
unfulfillment oh
unfulfillment so stop
them because you know how futile they
are you know they don't bring you
fulfillment you know they just bring you
suffering so stop
them and when those
stop what is left is what you have never
left
it's God's will for the new
world it's that
simple
just a moment to truly relax into the
Christ that is inside
already
and to truly
feel where
one should still
repent where one should still
forgive where one should still
heal
diving into all of those
fearlessly and
watching how those contractions
expand more and more into the kingdom of
the
father
and feeling more and
more of the father as the
totality as the father's wrath against
Injustice
as the father's expansion of all of the
planet's
contractions of all of its traumas to be
healed for separation to no longer be
seen
for innocent children women men to all
be abundant and prosperous with basic
needs and free energy in the new
Earth letting God's will Channel through
the body through the body for that new
world getting complet completely out of
the way through crucifixion completely
out of the way for God's will to
Shepherd the new
world a world without
corruption a world without greed
a world without hoarding without
selfishness without ego without
malevolence without violence without
war with such radical
abundance in energy and
prosperity that even the need for money
is
obsoleted
every
day all waking up free the entire
totality of your body called Earth
waking up
free creating celebrating
playing every day in perfect harmony
with nature and
Technology
the kingdom of God is
here the Kingdom of Heaven Is
Here Paradise is
here through
Christ it shall
be do not pretend like you know better
than Christ
because you
don't so take the
portal It's Your Divine Birthright take
the
portal take the
crucifixion take the
rebirth and let God's will Shepherd the
new
world
and so it
is
amen and so it